[Musique]
c'était pour moi à l'époque paisible des
jours heureux en ce temps là je me les
fronts peine les petits ruisseaux le
gave de pau qui poule est clair j'allais
dans les bois aussi ramasser des
châtaignes et chercher des champignons
c'était un grand bois de chêne
je me souviens au près d'une fontaine où
le président faisait des siennes
maintenant point ne fait bon devenir
vieux plus jamais je n'irai au mois et
si le printemps fait des siennes auprès
de la fontaine du grand bois plus jamais
ni frais des miennes
ça c'est le début de mémoire que j'ai
écrit comme ça de temps en temps quand
le temps passé sur gitans - et quand
j'aime me pencher un peu sur les
souvenirs du temps passé non d'entre eux
lui
noah chi sonné
le jeu
les pieuvres
[Applaudissements]
l'eau arrive
oh
fra
je sais je
je
le gène et mamou vieux je viens de faire
et
larrieu
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ce propos elle me rappelle mon enfance
étant donné que j'ai été à l'école ici
et ensuite ça me rappelle un peu plus
tard quand j'ai été instituteur adjoint
des fois quand vous voyez ces enfants
est-ce que vous retrouver l'enfant que
vous étiez long voyez maintenant
regardez comment ils sont habillés et
why elle leur tablier est vallier danic
nous nous avions toujours le tablier
noir le tablier et et noir à cette
époque la goutte au nez derrière avec
les trois boutons est lié par une
ceinture revers des ailes à des bottes
elle
mais nous nous avions simplement les
galoches de points il y a autre chose
aussi vous avez pu constater qu'ils
avaient le ballon
nous n'en avions pas parce qu'il ne
fallait pas cassé les vitres et ce qui
me rappelle encore quelque chose quand
nous voulions jouer au bar et à ce
moment là
eh bien nous partions en nous tenant par
le court et et nous appelions qui veut
jouer au bar qui veut jouer au var
haléco allemand j'ai commencé l'école
sans savoir comment ça va commencer
j'allais à l'école comme sa part que
l'instituteur était mon ami et je m'en
allais à l'école c'était monsieur broca
père qui était là et monsieur broca fils
lui avec la grande école moi je rentrais
à la petite école en me levant sur la
pointe des pieds je pressais sur le
champ de la porte d'entrée sur le
poignet de la porte d'entrée et je
rentrais aussitôt monsieur broca le père
qui faisait lire les enfants sur le
livre rose le livre rose le livre puis
sable à ce moment-là il
ils me voyaient arriver tiens tu es là
alors il me permet sur ses genoux et il
me chantait dans le plan sur ses genoux
et tous les élèves autour de lui avec le
livre cuissard et et alors les élèves
pour de lui écouter ne disait rien mais
moi je sautais sur ses genoux j'avais à
ce moment là trois ans le 4 à 3 ans
allait me faisait sauter sur ses genoux
mais il me chantait enjoint du mérite et
en juin 2008 ont enjoint duty l'humilité
du mirliton voilà c'était tout ce qu'il
disait mais mirliton fut pour moi mon
premier mot musicalement
[Musique]
il faut dire à ce moment là il faut tout
de même une considération générale
s'impose c'est l'oeuvre magnifique
scolaire de la troisième république
la troisième république a établi la
laïcité de l'état et à enlever aux
congrégations le soin de former la
jeunesse elle a pris ce soin pour elle
est admirablement dans chaque village de
france
une petite école ou même relativement
grande avec un instituteur et un
instituteur voué à sa charge
passionné pour apprendre les éléments
aux enfants des paysans du village et
l'école était devenu un centre du
village et l'instituteur bientôt
secrétaire de la mairie dirigeait toute
administration du village et ses écoles
ont fait les enfants qui ont été les
soldats de 14 ils marchent bien tu n'en
as oui vous aviez quel âge en 1914
monsieur le chien j'avais 11
ça veut dire que j'étais un peu trop
petits on vous rappelez du début de la
guerre petit jour où il est j'étais
petit oui mais quand même
j'avais des frères aînés au nom et qui
sont partis à la guerre
alors je me rappelle toujours de ce
départ je me rappelle est marié ou
savait et ma foi ensemble c'est un
souvenir
je me rappelle y en avait qui venait de
travail et dont on faisait du point
quand ils sont arrivés qu'ils ont vu d
affichage ils s'embrassaient tellement
qu'ils étaient contents de partir à la
guerre
mais moi je me rappelle mon père était
lui l'avenir 50 55 ans par là la vérité
mais il avait ces fils qui part de
ceux-là mais n'était pas vous savez ils
n'étaient pas angoissé il était même
fier d'avoir des fils qui part derrière
[Musique]
quelle est l'ambiance parmi les jeunes
de votre âge
c'était pathétique même genre
d'instituteurs même chouih même chez les
instituteurs jeu femmme sur tout et vous
avez aussi des dans une école normale
d'instituteurs oui oui oui
c'est alors que j'ai vu chez les filles
oui
[Musique]
ap
à ce moment là nous ferions l'exercice
militaire avec des fusils de bois n'est
ce pas dans la cour du lycée les chars
sous les ordres heures un capitaine
d'infanterie très patriote sport nous
avions des fusils à moi à oui oui à
l'école à l'épaule
[Musique]
un petit soldat français et n'oubliez
jamais la marseillaise c'est le champ de
liberté que la france a ajouté dans
l'informel en souvenir des héros de la
somme et de vos défendez le drobo eux si
l'on vous le trajet tous sens aussi du
danger
tout comme nos aïeux chargé mais les
leçons de morale de civisme c'est on
appelait ça des leçons de civisme de
morale était donnée été très suivi et
écouté nous arrivions 9 heures précises
et nous rentrions me replace en rend
bien sûr et nous commencions tout de
suite la leçon la première leçon c'était
de la morale au ralenti mora le mardi
mercredi instruction civique vendredi
moral et samedi la lecture du samedi
il ne le furent morale n'est ce pas la
morale est une science qui vous enseigne
faire le bien et à éviter le mal étudié
la morale c'est apprendre assez bien
conduire et être raisonnable pour
apprendre assez bien conduire il faut se
connaître soi même être attentif aux
bons conseils suivre l'exemple de nos
parents et de nous aider
à l'époque cette relation ne le lisez ça
il y avait le ministre comme emile
combes
comme vous avez dit voilà je ne supprime
pas les écoles est libre mais celui ci
pourra se les payer seul et pena et
alors il en a créé le colonat hic
gratuite et obligatoire pour tous les
français moi j étais à l'école mais j'en
ai vu de vonage il n'est jamais allé à
l'école qui ne serait pas parler
français
pourquoi il n'avait pas les moyens n'est
pas de s'acheter des vêtements pour
prévoir pour les envoyer à l'école et
alors il n'y allait pas
moi si j'avais été à l'école était
commun dit j'espère oui si j'avais été à
l'école mais je vous avait été pourtant
je suis était même aux saveurs demain on
me faisait garder le petit ma mère
allait touche à mon père était maçon de
ce métier
alors ces nomades qui gardait les petits
les autres mais vous y alliez combien de
fois par semaine et enfin que je pouvais
je dimanche pour espérer comme le centre
[Musique]
monsieur le bâtonnier petit vous aviez à
l'école bouge pas beaucoup
pourquoi vous n'y allez pas beaucoup et
parce que j'avais eue avant l'été
prochain
et oui les vaches si vous y alliez
combien de fois par semaine là on y voit
un peu en froid avec pas mais monsieur
broca n'a donné la vocation d'un twitter
j'étais tout le temps à l'école et ceci
explique que ce soit devenu plus tard
l'instituteur je suis resté ensuite avec
monsieur broca j'ai appris à lire
comment dans son livre dans ce livre
cuissard ce livre cuissardes qui
existent encore mais qui est rare dont
on ne se sert plus bien sûr qu'ils
existent
les gardes comme une relique maintenant
ce livre cuissard était composée des
voyelles simplement à un îlot une
grecque nous les connaissions ses
voyelles parce qu'il y avait une image
qui caractérisait chaque voyelle à cette
étonnante eux c'était trois heures d'un
sommet qui s'était une île mais y
je me souviens c'était un attaquant
[Musique]
nous avions ensuite le livre bleu dans
le livre bleu pour n'apprenait à ce
moment là les consonnes à buck de feu
gay éxcède 1mo vision a bu que deux on
ne disait pas a b c d e f g à cergy et
c'est un nom on disait à buck de ce qui
nous faisait dire en géographie
quand nous allions devant la carte de
vidal lablache lorsque nous allions
taper avec une baguette pour apprendre
les préfectures et les sous-préfectures
et pour apprendre les différentes mais
revault apprenions la mer méditerranée
je me souviens de ça on nous disait le
rhône à une rapidité excessive c'est
comme un torrent qui descend évidemment
pour nous à cet âge là le rhône c'était
quelque chose parce qu'il descendait à
la verticale de la carte vidal lablache
[Musique]
et alors ils nous disions ceci la
méditerranée je vous récite tels que
cela était écrit dans la géographie
française la méditerranée à la forme de
rond dans ce renversé au lieu dit du
nain se renverser et le creux de le ce
le cros de l'ess est le golfe de lion
voilà ce que nous restions et c'était
amy d'une façon parfaite
voilà donc pour la géographie nous nous
apprenions ensuite le calcul et puis
nous chantions également et mon premier
chan a été celui ci ce beau temps de
pâques oeufs est ravigotant pierre
antoine et jacques rentrer en chantant
un que l'on va rire car le ciel est
clair
et chacun respire la gaieté dans l'air
le deuxième show m'étais je me suis levé
bon matin l'heure a sonné cinq ou de
suite
il faisait jour j'ai pris la fuite à
travers notre grand jardin tintin la
coquette nature fraîche et pure souris y
est au matin
si vous vous souvenez de livres que vous
ayez lunel
c'est donc la double d'un cousin qui
c'est sûr mais ne pas céline dussaud
robin ou les cartes et parce que c'est
encore que j'ai eue au mali pour lui le
mi6 bourget et puis j'ai vernaton france
j'ai lu des livres qui étaient même
condamné foyer et je ne le savais pas
il devait partir de livres condamnée par
par les vl et égalise
oui et bien la séparation lundi le les
gosses nos démarches allaient à l'école
celle ci vise à inciter à les amener à
la messe
s'ils venaient à la messe et après la
messe les oies salaires amené les
chercheurs à l'école rappelé 31 et les
appellations d'origine inao
j'ai eu de blessé à l'épaule il allait à
la baisse séoul et si vous voulez parier
pas et les lois ça c'était les valeurs
qu'ils jugent aux penseurs à tous les
précurseurs aux ouvriers de la tâche
immortel aux penseurs à tous les
précurseurs à jean macé des hymnes rezé
des fleurs ils ont lutté pour l'humanité
pour l'avenir d'une cité fraternelle
ils ont lutté pour l'humanité pour l'un
venir et pour la liberté aux penseurs
extra et c'est parce que nous avions
appris c'est quelque chose qui a marqué
ça aussi et qui a marqué la chanson la
chanson et jean macé c'était un moment
l'espagne où il y avait peut-être
séparation de l'église et de l'état ou
bien l'école laïque d'un côté l'école
privée de l'autre ça se passait en 1905
sa et la différence était grande après
la loi de combat à la différence ça
c'est la france a été ramené par metz et
tours prague était pas content de ça des
parents vous voulez dire il y avait
différents qui était parti royaliste
à l'époque il y avait deux parties
et le parti royaliste et le passé alors
qu'ils avaient adhéré au parti
républicain qui jusqu'àlors ne vais pas
en parler niemi et pourquoi il faisait
par ailleurs le village a été séparé en
2 1 à l'aller a même il ya même eu des
riches propriétaires utilisés à leur
métier
si vous envoyez la par à l'école laïque
geoffroy portes il y en a qui l'ont fait
mais tout de même ça s'est pas produit
parce qu'il ya des indices se sont
mobilisées jeudi
nous enverrons revenant mais grâce à
l'école laïque et c'est comme ça alors
petit à petit ça s'était calmé et n'a
pas c'était arrivé les curés était
partie au régime comme les autres et il
s'arrangeait va le placer nature le
danger vient des traditions de notre
suivi
vous menez et y en avoir qui sommes pro
briser notre île ne sont pas sages ont
lieu les 10 et ça me sera toujours ça
alors ça tu es comme aujourd'hui les
jaunes du côté catholique elle est rouge
du coupon en disaient les rouges
c'était dans les radicaux elle est jaune
et bien cette attitude du pape dise que
le papa impôts jour dont je crois est-ce
que la la séparation de l'église et de
l'état vous a touché dans notre famille
moi ça ne m'a pas touché on sait dans la
rage ça nous a réjouis c'était une
famille républicaine
c'est à dire que vous à gt gt avec un
libertaire à cette époque là votre père
vous votre père avoue il était de quel
parti à mon père quand l'angola est
établie il avait vie moi j'avais l'école
des gosses à l'école c'était un
républicain
on peut le dire maintenant il ne risque
plus rien votre peine
vous étiez combien dans cette maison que
vous étiez petit 80 le père à merde
qu'est ce que sont devenus vos frères et
soeurs et la haye moi il le morgen du
coeur et le 2 autres le seront encore en
vie est lancé le père à l'ingénieur
celui qui est en amérique qui était
junior
30 15 je vous voir quelquefois au de
temps en temps pas trop selon à signer
leurs inspecteurs ne vais pas me voir on
n'aime pas on n'est pas mêmes partis
vous en prie mais qu'il pensait à à 16
et ne va pas vous lisiez ça fait en
cachette
si les élections se voir en cachette
chez accor massa miné oui mais vous avez
bien le droit de dire quel est votre
vrai nom c'est dangereux
je ne me mets pas mon bras le ville ça
pourquoi il vous demande plus pourquoi
il faut pas oublier faut pas le dire
c'est un péché et c'est pas pêcher
s'épanouit fait c'était un péché
vous vous à vous avez du musée moi j'ai
rod alors que palau dit et si jamais on
avait le même comment peut-on recevoir à
m
dans tous les villages
l'inventaire dans les visites et
et le presbytère partout pour voir ce
que possédait le clergé
[Musique]
des anciens jour entendu j'aurais des
siens
[Musique]
gary qu'il y en ait eu un boom bass
aussi à oui oui et comment ça s'est
passé elle a hébergé saas et ça s'est
passé que il y avait une grande partie
de même de changes qui étaient l'un
partis religieux qui s'était enfermé
arriviste et qui attendait les autorités
il ya là les gendarmes et y avait des
choses nous les chasseurs militaires y
est devenu et le préfet a permis aux
autorités qu'ils étaient venus les le
village était encerclé par la
gendarmerie par l'aja paris alors l'iss
appelée une compagnie de jeux de
l'infanterie y était venu pour aider les
comment ceux qui venaient faire
l'inventaire
alors comment ça s'est su je n'en sais
rien baru d'un il y en a eu et qu'il a
su qu'il était un peu plus haut elle est
morte il ya déjà la maman était alors et
leur sens de cloche oui l'été show ne
passe que sonnaient les cloches
ah oui parce que l'armée a dû venir par
la route ou alors comme il allait
travailler à l'usiné
le régisseur le bonheur ils ont vu toute
la troupe qui venaient ils ont qu'à
douai nallet l'année vers l'église
alors elle elle a trouvé le moyen passé
comme ça je suis pas la pile filet comme
ça dans la troupe
ils n'ont pas prêté attention est la
rentrée à l'église qui l a été sonné les
cloches ont volé c'est elle qui les a
sauvés maintenant c'est elle et elle
seule dose de cloche
on ne peut qu on savait que les cloches
qu'avec une connerie elle n'était pas là
on ne s'est pas lectrique il n'a pas
sonné les cloches maintenant sur le cac
le relais tout le monde en était sur
pied tout le monde en sortie alors ces
contrats passé puisqu'il y avait un
trouble qui tenait alors ils ont bien de
l'avenir de l'église le père prise en
partie ils ont mis à la porte naturelle
presbytère iommi il y aurait eu cent ans
au lit devant la porte
et puis il est parti c'était tout
beaucoup de répercussions l'inventaire
ici non non on à la veste et mais enfin
ça s'est passé calmement il n'y a pas eu
de protestation violente je dirais on
n'a pas cassé les serrures
on s'est fait à l'amiable quand même oui
comme la plupart des temps d'ailleurs
toutes ces cérémonies
toutes ces inventaires se dit long
[Musique]
l'application de ces lois qui était on
appelait les lois scélérates à l'époque
mais ça s'est passé très calmement et
moi c'est verra comme le disait au fond
ils ont bien rendu service l'état de
s'emparer des églises parce que s'il
fallait que nous réparions tout seul les
paroisses en arriverons pas
il n'y a pas de répercussion lointaine
c'est fini on emporte ne parle plus
moi je n'attends rien de parler en ce
moment là et c'était à l'époque de
première communion tous les deux alors
le curé d'un côté mais de maître d'école
de l'autre c'était la bagarre et nous
les gosses on était entre les deux le
maître d'école sonner son école à 8
heures pile le pur et n'avait pas fini
son catéchistes à le curé redonner son
catéchisme aux heures de médicaux
n'avaient pas fini sa leçon
c'était absolument la poire et ça a duré
peut-être non peut-être plus dans wii
jusqu'au jour où où l'évêque a changé le
curé et l'inspecteur a changé
l'instituteur tout est rentré dans
j'étais rentré dans l'ordre n'a pas fait
grand chose mais c'est le secteur là que
ça se passe et en quelle année ça oui
oui ça s'appelle le gab
je sais que c'est le gave de pau ceci je
l' ai appris lorsque j'allais en classe
suspendue mais nous l'appelions l'ogaf
tout court j'avais 7 ans 8 ans et je
venais au gars venu pour me baigner
il y avait également des jeunes filles
qui se baignait aussi qui était charmant
très gentille des amis de l'école mais
qui se baignait elle faisant que l'autre
n'est en maillot de bain qui se met y
est simplement avec le tablier et ce
tablier à ce moment-là coller une fois
qu'elles s'étaient baignés n'est ce pas
cool et sur elle les femmes d'une façon
une façon formidable qui me permettait
de jeter un regard un regard anxieux et
de me poser malgré mon jeune âge n'est
ce pas quelques questions dont je ne
vous parlerai pas maintenant et pourquoi
non j'ai vu monter les jeunes de jajouka
fait mon choix est fait je ne veux pas
le droit fichier ne pensais pas mais bon
ici tapas lé dimanche n'étaient pas des
partis opposés comme ça me fallait
outre des sacres européens n'ont fait
que passer sa forme mc à la guerre de 14
tout était rentré dans l'ordre
c'est un épisode passager ça oui je
crois que les allemands il croyait
beaucoup arrivent de la division des
français avant 14 ans alors ils sont
aperçus quand même que 114 la guerre
tous les français se sont vite ensemble
ça n'a fait qu'un bloc
il y avait bien à l'école normale où
nous n'étions pas encore un groupe
extrémiste jettent à dire socialiste
avant fait il n'y a pas de communistes
bien entendu et 1 coupe talent à thala
voulant dire ceux qui montent à la mef
mais c'est tout ils étaient ils allaient
à la messe et les autres affiches et des
vides et non pas et non une ombre sur
les murs afficher des idées avancées et
aurait été antimilitariste s'il n'y
avait pas eu la guerre de 14 qui est non
seulement une aventure mais ne l'oublié
pas alors c'est pas seulement c'est une
aventure une aventure où on a bonne
conscience
j'ai quelques souvenirs d'antan ne m'a
jamais quitté j'habite est assez loin du
quartier du 20e de rayon à limoges gt1
garnison et tous les matins elle fr -
d'instruction à cheval et cela me
donnait l'occasion de traverser une
place publique à la place carnot je
crois sur laquelle les ouvriers d'aviles
en attendaient l'heure d'ouverture du
travail il gagne pas beaucoup d'argent y
regarder à deux fois avant d'aller
s'installer au café pour faire la
dépense d'un verre de vin rouge et du
vin blanc et lors ces gens me voyaient
traverser à cheval suivi de mon
ordonnance également à cheval
qu'est-ce que je représentais pour eux à
ce moment là la classe aisée
les gens qui travaillent et peut-être
mais dans le travail n'était pas pénible
il y avait h moments de grandes
différences sociales et on n'avait pas
fait grand chose pour abaisser les
différences qu'il y avait entre les gens
très riches les gens très pauvres et je
sentais dans cette foule d'ouvriers qui
se séparer pour me laisser passer comme
une nuance d'hostilité et je sentais
quand j'avais dépassé les conversations
se taisaient en truck et toutes les
visières de leur casquette se tourner
dans la même direction
il visait dans le dos quand j'avais
dépassé leur foule
j'étais gêné ça ça m'ennuyait et bien le
jour de la mobilisation
j'ai donc retraverser toute cette même
foule et à ce moment là je représentais
pour ces ouvriers autre chose que ce que
je vais étaient ils ont tous enlever
leurs casquettes comme celui très bas et
ils ont dit certains vivent l'armée
eh ben ça souvenirs je n'ai pas oublié
ça
[Musique]
voilà le mot la cellule on prie on va
préparer
[Musique]
je
à tous les camarades
[Musique]
l'oublier
voilà
ou est-ce que vous avez été élevé
monsieur le cul à bapaume
je suis resté à bapaume jusqu'à l'âge de
16 ans c'est à l'âge de 16 ans que je
suis venu à l'enfance malheureuse était
vraiment vous dire ni région de
l'échelle sociale
cette gosse plus de père la mère à laon
les 6 à 3 francs 3 francs cinquante par
jour et en droit au repas du soir
mais voulant le prendre avec ses enfants
le modem employeur de lui mettre dans un
papier spécial nous attendions sa
rentrée impatiemment gestion des projets
qui ne demandent yoka sauter sur la mort
et naturellement ce qu'on lui donne et
même largement parce que les employeurs
connaissait la situation
il suffisait quand même pas pour calmer
c'est notre appétit alors terminé avec
le fromage à l'époque on appelait
fromage à quatre russes ou et surtout le
pain l'ouvrier et la classe ouvrière
moi j'attends à manger beaucoup de pain
on amorce plus maintenant notre époque
on a mangé et quand j'entends parler de
la belle époque que ça me faire laisser
les cheveux sur la tête parce que la
belle époque en 1907 et la misère pour
le peuple et c'était la belle époque aux
gros noyau voilà est-ce que je résume
pas qu'aux bien que j'ai raison
mais nous faisait pas partie du noyau
dans le milieu social ou qu'elle nous
appartenions c'est à dire la petite
bourgeoisie qui n'étaient pas riches qui
n'était pas pauvre qui gagnait sa vie
assez durement mais qui la gagne est il
y avait une
ambiance il y avait une douceur de vivre
il y avait une manière de sourire
il y avait une manière de ne pas avoir
besoin de trop s'occuper de l'avenir
tout en occupant beaucoup l'avenir
j'entends le lendemain c'était quelque
chose de merveilleux et tous les gens
qui étaient autour de cette petite
bourgeoisie
nous avions une vieille dame qui venait
tous les jeudis pour raccommoder le
linge qu'on envoyait à la lessive
puisque mes parents avaient une petite
pension de famille il y avait pas mal de
linge elle était pauvre son bail était
menuisier
elle avait deux fils et on parle
longuement avec elle et tout ça c'était
doux tout ça c'était en douceur
[Musique]
rien de dur ma mère aimait et respectait
cette dame elle elle n'avait rien de
serviles mais elle rendait de grands
services avec douceur avec minutie
c'était vraiment c'est oui c'était une
belle époque ce n'était pas la belle
époque
loin de là c'est une époque de misère
travail et du matin au soir et n'a rien
gagné 2 du dé lever au coucher du soleil
effet la nuit même n'est ce pas pour ne
rien gagner pourrait sévir vous n'avez
pas de bons souvenirs de cette époque là
aucun bon souvenir
c'était devenu la mi temps paveurs qui
s'appelait vont kane un brave type dont
le métier consistait à taper avec un
instrument sur les pavés de paris
j'avais jeté entré chez lui j'avais vu
son logis j'avais vu le soin
extraordinaire que prenait sa femme pour
qu'il soit propre bien tenu et la toile
cirée qui étaient sur la table soit bien
laver et il m'avait montré son petit
garçon qui était un petit garçon
peut-être de trois ans
très pâle et très mou et bien j'ai le
souvenir voyez-vous quand il m'a montré
cet enfant je lui donnais lui dit donnez
le moi je les prie dans mes bras et j'ai
le souvenir qu'en portant ce petit
bonhomme qui dans mes bras
dans ce baiser râble logis devant mon
brave ami week-end
je tenais toute la misère du monde
j'ai commencé comme ça te ruisseau chez
un notaire vous appointements de 15
cents par mois à l'époque
et puis à la mort de mon patron je ne me
suis pas entendu avec son successeur est
plus ou moins vous aviez 16 ans oui
j'avais 16 ans et vous travaillez déjà
depuis depuis l'âge de 13 ans mon patron
notaire est en or lors un successeur est
arrivé il s'est fait présenter le
personnel le bureau comme j'étais saute
ruisseau ces bons qui suit pas ces
derniers le contact n'a pas été mauvais
jeudi on va s'entendre
puis peu de temps après alors sa femme
est arrivée avec ses enfants
et un beau jour la porte de l'étude
s'ouvre et saddam m'appelle alors me
voilà dans le vestibule avec elle elle
me dit petitclerc vous allez conduire
mes deux fils à l'école
je me dit madame je suis venu ici pour
apprendre le métier de notaire et non
pas pour être bonne d'enfants elle fiche
son camp voir un patron et peu de temps
après je suis appelé par le patron qui
était vraiment gêné de cet incident car
déjà il tenait à moi je connaissais la
clientèle faisait les encaissements et
pat amant alors il veut me faire
comprendre que mon individualité il va
pas en souffrir en conduisant les gosses
à l'école julie carrément non et puisque
vous insistez je vous donne ma démission
notre jeunesse gratter heureux ayant
joui de toutes les jouissances de la
belle époque fut placée en présence de
la misère du début du prolétariat
c'est qu'après la sphère dreyfus comme
le parti socialiste naissant comme
jaurès avec mener le combat
parmi les dreyfusards les professeurs de
ce temps on dit mais il faut que nous
allions voir les ouvriers ils nous ont
aidé à rétablir la justice à nous à les
aider à rétablir la justice sociale
on avait fondé les universités
populaires à l'école supérieure à ce
moment-là nous suivions une
bien droite je vous assure le dimanche
il fallait partir à la mer on est allé à
la messe nous partirons endroit deux par
deux nous arrivions dans l'église et
nous vous mettions un endroit qui nous
était réservé parce que nous savions que
de l'autre côté du coeur de l'autre côté
du cor montrent côté de l'église quoi
des places il y avait à ce moment là les
jeunes filles du cours secondaire que
nous appelions l'équipe est du court les
l'équipe est du coup l'équipe us du
cours sont là c'était une école laïque
sera révolu et l'école supérieure et le
cours secondaire s'était également en
cours secondaire laïque est alors chacun
regardez la sienne et si la percevait
parmi les chaises n'est ce pas il y
avait un petit clin d'oeil une petite
employée n'est ce pas qu'on saluer le
saint sacrement mais ont salué la petite
jeune fille n'est ce pas qui était là et
on était content si elle vous avez
reconnu
voilà que les études des sentiments
amoureux que l'on pouvait avoir
et après la main si vous aviez le droit
de sortir en ville de sortir en ville et
d'aller chez vos parents alors à
grenelle s'était fondé une université
populaire l'émanciper trice et nous y
allions et nous rencontrions les
ouvriers jeunes et vieux y avait encore
la dune vieux survivants de la commune
de paris
et puis des jeunes et avec eux nous
jouions des comédies et nous lisions des
poètes
moi je me rappelle l'avant 14 quand
j'avais 15 ans
14 15 ans je faisais des kilomètres à
pied pour aller par exemple à la lumière
c'était populaire du faubourg saint jean
du faubourg saint-antoine antoine la
coopération des idées ça s'appelait et
il y avait là une salle où on se
retrouvait tous les toutes les semaines
ou tous les quinze jours et j'ai eu là
c'est parce que c'était des cours
vraiment qu'on nous donnait nous avons
vu la qualif la marijuana tall france la
grande collecte d'autres que je ne me
rappelais exactement les noms comme
celui qui venait nous apprendre quelque
chose que quand nous sortions delà nous
avions quelque chose de plus je suis
venu à arras
je suis entré à la société générale et à
la générale mais après tu mens était
médiocre alors que je voyais défiler
devant moi des sacs des culs de louis
vuitton et tente dans le service
comptable je voyais des jalles des
comptes courants dont le crédit était
assez élevé pour arriver parce que je
n'avais mon obsession c'était de pouvoir
envoyer un peu d'argent à ma mère elle
les appointements mais après tu ne le
permettait pas alors la matière grise
travail et mijoté ses deux filles en
aiguilles
c'est ça qui m'a conduit à être un
révolté
alors nous avions tous l'idée que pour
changer cet état
il fallait une révolution qu'on ne
pouvait pas arriver à transformer ce
monde sont un événement révolutionnaire
marcel cachin est venu avec raoul
briquet raoul briquet avocat à lens qui
a été député d'arras sont venus faire
une conférence dans la rue des
trois-visages arras j'y suis allé et je
me suis fait inscrire parti socialiste
quittait le parti de jean jaurès
c'était le party c'est à dire le parti
socialiste à l'époque avait déjà
plusieurs tendances dans le parti
socialiste il y avait légué d'ist guesde
de roubaix la statuette à rodez jules
guesde jean jaurès et yahvé l'extrême
gauche qui est existe un ver vais le
drapeau dans le fumier les ervices tu
sais ce que vous étiez alors c'est
devenu naturellement 18 ans un service
vous étiez la bande à baader de l'époque
à l'époque oui sans tout de même procédé
à avoir recours à des engins explosifs
non c'était pas connu à l'époque mais
enfin j'ai vu l'anarchie il ya eu les
attentats les anarchistes était un peu
au dessus des socialistes il y avait les
anarchistes à l'époque était sébastien
faure surtout sébastien faure quoi qui
et dirigé la rue la rue de rambouillet
si j'ai bonne mémoire
en 1905 il y avait je crois le premier
1er mai véritablement ouvriers et il
était question de faire entièrement
grève ce jour-là en sorte que les
familles des petits bourgeois qui allait
au lycée était fort inquiète d'y envoyer
leurs fils ce jour là tous les magasins
étaient fermés et on s'attendait d'une
minute à l'autre
a voir je ne sais quoi surgir de
quelques horizons
je suis allé au lycée charlemagne avec
l'impression que je sais quelque chose
de dangereux
voilà est encore parmi parmi sept cette
école cette secte elle se scinder en
deux il y avait les libertaires et les
anarchistes
alors les anarchistes était encore plus
avancé que les libertaires
il y avait des anarchiste individualiste
comme bono la bande à bonnot alors là
c'est lé badernes à l'époque ça c'était
bien ça celui que les services est lui
qui a commencé n'est ce pas faire un
hold up
bono et mais disons qu'il n'était pas
prise et en général même même par lui
même des anarchistes
une fois je ne suis pas sorti parce que
je n'en chantillon quelquefois à 8h30 de
l'après midi du soir le samedi soir
champion
alors chapeau maladie de quelque chose
et moi je chantais un une chanson devant
tous mes collègues et je tends ma ligne
au hasard de l'autre côté je n'en sors
gare et tout en suivant le bouchon je
taquine bout
et tout en suivant le bouchon je
taquinais voulons alors il y avait une
dame qui ôte à son corsage rose au
moment où je disais la dame août à son
corsage rose
je vis bien qu'il cachait quelque chose
aussitôt la porte s'ouvre la porte de
quatrième année la salle de classe et
c'est le directeur le directeur rentrer
j'entends une voix qui me dit le patron
aussitôt j'arrête quelques secondes de
retard et je reprends inconstante
bergeronnettes pauvre petit oiseau
deschamps qui voltigent vive et coquette
et qui sifflent de jolis fonds vert
jaune est si gentille la porte du fonds
se referme le directeur s'en va et je me
dis personne ne pensera plus le
directeur aura totalement oublié c'était
donc le samedi soir et le dimanche
j'avais fait une demande pour la sortie
dominicale
le lendemain matin au moment où je
m'apprêtais à partir
le directeur me fait appeler et me lie
la punition que j'avais d'aînesse privés
de sortie le dimanche prochain parce que
ils passent de la chanson osé à
inconstante bergeronnettes et ce jour là
je restais à l'école supérieure alors
les français on craint que les allemands
les uns à nouveau face naguère lots
patriotisme qui pendant la flambée
sociale avait été un peu écarté a repris
toute sa force
il suffit de lire les cahiers de la
quinzaine de pays
pour voir l'évolution de ce mouvement
la première période sociale avec les
récits de la vie des instituteurs avec
les comptes rendus des congrès
socialiste avec toute la littérature
en faveur de la révolution ouvrière et
puis ensuite tout le redressement en
disant ce pays va être attaqué par le
militarisme allemand
nous avons à défendre sa liberté
nous avons à défendre l'esprit de
justice
nous avons à défendre l'esprit
républicain car l'esprit républicain
était quelque chose cela signifiait
quelque chose d'être républicain ce
temps ça avait une signification morale
contre si vous voulez lempire allemand
mars et de sa vague peut-être oublié
aujourd'hui il était très connu en 1914
il n'est décrit un bouquin fort
intéressant qui ceinturait s'intituler
fait un roi sinon on fait la paix alors
nous avons sauté la grille du lycée la
nuit vers 10 heures du soir au fond du
parc pour ceux qui se connaissent le
lycée lakanal à sceaux la grille avait
quand même 4 ou 5 mètres de hauteur et
il y avait des piquants vous enfin on
s'en est bien tirée au clair de lune
on est arrivé au meeting pour entendre
marcel st bas qui vous avez assez
impressionné en standard
et puis après après malfrats étaient les
élections qui noté ont été un succès
pour le move ce qui fait qu'on aura à ce
paradoxe bien connu que c'est la gauche
pacifiste qui prend le couloir et qui
trois mois plus tard sous le fait de les
circonstances sera obligé de prendre des
mesures de guerre
le 2 août et au et je me rappelle le
jour qu'on a assassiné jeunesse
l'assassinât de jeunesse il a été
assassinée vers la cheville est temps de
31,8 pas vous dire exactement le jour je
me rappelle pas mais je me rappelle que
les structures appelées et il nous a dit
maintenant vous partez je crois que
l'heureux vous vous partez en vacances
et nous partons à la guerre on assassine
jaurès parce qu'il ne le pourrait pas
une pension peut-être que je ré serait
arrivé à décider la social-démocratie
les éléments de la social démocratie je
l'aimerais a empêché le mans allemande à
empêcher la guerre
nous avions très peu confiance mais
enfin c'est celui qui tombe à l'eau et
qui cherche une touffe d'herbe sur la
berge pour essayer de ne pas de ne pas
tomber de ne pas aller au fond n'est pas
les plus révolutionnaires d'entre nous
pensaient que cette guerre aboutirait à
la fin du militarisme à la fin de l'
impérialisme à la fin des restes de la
féodalité en europe
et je rappelle toujours ce mot de péguy
qui vendent ira geneviève favre je pars
soldats la république pour la dernière
des guerres mais six camarades et moi
vous signalera vous voulez dire qui
appartenait également d'évoluer
révolution ce petit club antimilitariste
nous nous sommes rencontrés à grande
synthe entre gravelines et dunkerque
pour décider pour savoir quels allaient
être neutre ' notre situation
notre décision notre marche à suivre est
l'un des nôtres a dit la république les
lois républicaines sont même supérieures
aux lois intériale du kaiser
on peut crier en france ce que l'on veut
s'en aller et le soir on prend prison
chasse il arrive qu'ils n'arriveraient
pas en allemagne
si quelqu'un voulait voir le libertaire
la guerre sociale dans les rues de
berlin
mais le soir ils se retrouveraient en
prison alors il ya donc davantage de
liberté ce la république et pas que sous
les lois du kaiser et je pense en notre
âme et conscience que nous devons
défendre le pays et nous avons voté et à
l'unanimité on vise à défendre le plie à
cette époque on n'avait vu qu'une chose
il y avait bien l'archiduc tués et
l'autriche hongrie et les russes
s'étaient pas fa qui nous préoccupe est
l'événement était entré voilà une chose
qu'on ne dira jamais a fait était entré
les premières avait déclaré la guerre
était entré en territoire français au
moment où le gouvernement viviani
avaient défilé fait chose inouïe et
extraordinaire que toutes les troupes
françaises devrait reculer de 10
kilomètres à l'intérieur des frontières
je ne sais pas si vous mesurez le bon
droit que ça que ça a l'air de données
et que ça donne
au fond honnêtement nous étions partagés
en lumière est ce que la guerre va
éclater ce qu'elle ne va pas être un
fait il faudrait qu'elles n'éclatent pas
ce serait affreux mais tout de même on
n'en peut plus on n'en peut plus on
attendait l'éclatement de l'orage et en
hôtel en l'état d'impatience où sont les
hommes et même les animaux lorsqu'on
orages se prépare et qui désire qu'il
éclate
est ce qu'il y avait moyen de préfère
retenir non valable il fallait alors là
il n'y avait rien à faire ce que vous
n'aurez hexabyte et le jus de la mer
bleue avait quand même en vous je crois
oui
[Musique]
et